what is happening there reject Nation we
are going to watch today the She-Hulk
pitch meeting John how are you I'm
excited for this I've been waiting for
this how are you good we haven't watched
the pitch meeting in a while I don't
even watch on my own time I can only do
it if there's a camera pointed and
obviously I actually watched them all
the time I was like we should do She
Hulk we've covered She-Hulk so much
smash that like button you know in the
reference and uh let's get to it
[Music]
so you have some new Disney plus content
for me yes sir I do although I am kind
of worried we might be over saturating
people with Marvel stuff at the moment
maybe we should take a breather between
projects for a sec no well okay then so
I was making my way down the list of
Marvel characters we haven't brought
into the MCU yet and I was thinking we
could make a She-Hulk show oh yeah we
haven't done that character yet that
sounds like money to me man it's a real
fun character she was breaking the
fourth wall even before Deadpool you
know I could see that working well in
Deadpool movies or comic books but do
you think it might lower the impact of
the overall MCU to have a character that
knows that they're in a Cinematic
Universe hey shut up so we're gonna meet
I will say that I don't feel like it
actually negatively affects it we did
watch Black Panther wakanda forever I
had a weird thought when we did finish
the finale of She-Hulk of will this
affect my future viewings of Marvel
movies and it didn't uh didn't bleed
over at all I didn't even think about it
till right now I remember having that
thought and I didn't have that thought
at all watching black panther yeah I
think it would only really detriment the
universe if you had like a bunch if like
most characters all of a sudden started
breaking the fourth wall and walking
around outside of it if shuri was
constantly breaking the floor She-Hulk
was in Black Panther wakanda forever so
we're gonna meet Jennifer Walters who's
a lawyer and also Bruce Banner's cousin
he's from the movies he sure is Sir and
so they get into a car accident and she
gets some of his blood in her blood oh
unexpected blood combos are tight okay
so since they're related she turns into
a Hulk as well oh wow wow wow wow and so
Bruce is gonna show her some cool stuff
about being a Hulk like you can drink
alcohol and not get drunk why would you
want that pretty cool right not really
that's so true and I feel like they've
pointed that out before with Steve
Rogers yeah that was that was a negative
thing for Steve was he was trying to
escape from his pain and he couldn't get
away from his pain because he can't get
drunk but at least Jen can switch back
and get immediately way too drunk and
give herself off liver poison I'm sure
the person is out there but I've never
personally met someone who's like God I
love the taste of this drink but I just
hate the feeling of getting intoxicated
so he's gonna teach her and try to guide
her through these new powers and she's
gonna kind of make fun of him and insult
him so that's gonna be fun that kind of
makes her seem a little rude and mean
he's just trying to help her because he
cares about her well she doesn't really
want his help plus she's already kind of
mastered the whole Hulk thing already oh
she has yes sir she's already fantastic
and agile and she could turn into
She-Hulk at will without losing control
of herself at all that was that possible
I feel like it took Bruce a long time to
master all that well Jen explains to
Bruce that because she's been cat called
and mansplained too and some men are
straight up dangerous she's much better
at controlling her anger than Bruce
because she's had to do it infinitely
more than he has okay yeah no I mean I
see what she's saying and in no way do I
want to belittle what women have to go
through at all careful but also she's
saying this to Bruce Banner who saved
the planet multiple times and lost his
best friend and his love interest and
was turned into a monster and chased by
governments and turned into a gladiator
slave on an alien planet tried to take
his own life it's like of all people
Bruce yeah okay so I hear what you're
saying and it's there's even more in his
backstory for you to point that out oh
okay my bad it's too late you're on a
list now you can't have any opinions
about this show without being classified
as being on one extreme of a very
complicated issue God dang it I hate
being on the list so anyway Jen canceled
producer guy cancel him I gotta pause
this just to be like that was really
well handled yes yes this is extremely
well-handed really great way to tiptoe
it's a very you got to compliment Ryan
George when he Nails it on handling a
sensitive subject like that in a way
that points out that we maybe don't need
to be as hyper sensitive about it you
know what do you mean that's the whole
point of watching these things Jen goes
back to her life as a lawyer enduring a
trial a super powered influencer which
is a thing in the MCU now apparently
burst through the wall uh-oh and so then
towards the end of the first episode
Jen's gonna turn into She-Hulk and
everyone's gonna learn that she has
powers wow and so what else do we find
out in the first episode all right well
you know Captain America yeah but it's
PP and a lady wow
your job and gets hired at another firm
to start like a superhero live division
okay so this becomes kind of like a
lawyer show ah kind of sometimes a
little do you know scenes nope and then
so also
life kind of show like Jen's gonna go on
dates and stuff right okay does she also
fight crime or not so much so like what
what happens oh well stuff you know
sometimes all right is there can you you
gotta give me something please oh well
at a certain point she's gonna represent
a male Blonsky so that's gonna be pretty
cool I don't think I know who that is
remember you know he was in the movie
The 14 years Candy Man the movie oh yeah
okay yeah yeah no it wasn't a super
memorable character but yeah well it
doesn't really matter to be honest
because he's just a completely different
yes that's true it's all connected also
Wong is gonna show up sometimes he's
from the movies he isn't he's gonna
become friends with this girl Madison
and what's her deal she's always drunk
and she's the absolute best part of the
show nice also at a certain point
She-Hulk is gonna twerk with Megan the
stallion what superheroes don't usually
words people are gonna be like what and
then other people are gonna be you know
deeply angry about it oh my God what
you'll see that's gonna be kind of a
thing in the show we're going to kind of
rile up angry internet dudes and then
make fun of them for getting riled up
that's going to be really good for the
state of Internet discourse yeah with
all the toxicity online I'm pretty sure
that was my favorite part of covering
this show the Ridiculousness of it all
that engagement it's angry fans every
time I watch this I was like
you don't need to be upset no why are
you so upset
toad if you're offended why are you this
offended it's a big green lady we could
get past this it's a fantasy even if
this is real this is one of the sillier
tone shows anyway There Are Rules There
are rules if I had some friends in real
life who were offended by that where I
had an actual conversation with it with
them about it and if they were like um
if they could get me to see their
perspective maybe I would understand but
I really I I don't I don't understand
the level is what I'm talking about you
have disrespected the core foundations
of this character which they haven't I
know it seems like it'll be pretty well
within her wheelhouse given what we know
about Jim so any interesting plot
threads or anything I should know about
oh there's like this group of toxic
dudes that call themselves
Intelligentsia and they're trying to get
some of she-hulk's blood oh boy I bet
that's gonna come into play later the
hell was that noise oh yeah I heard it
what did it mean though we'll see we're
gonna get to the finale and it's gonna
be set up like a big Marvel Showdown you
know oh okay so there's gonna be this
toxic dude that turns it into a Hulk and
then Bruce shows up and Abominations
there and it's going to be this big
Showdown type thing uh gonna be hard for
her to get out of that situation
actually it's going to be super easy
barely an inconvenience oh really
because he Jen is gonna break the fourth
wall and be like is this working for
anyone okay she's gonna be like this is
kind of crappy right where this Show's
going it's not good that's we're making
the show we are yeah and so then she's
gonna go into the Disney plus menu and
eventually into the She-Hulk writers
room that is going up then eventually
meet with the head of Marvel who as it
turns out is just this creatively
bankrupt robot algorithm making
formulaic decisions based on what it
thinks is popular kind of hurtful and so
she's gonna get him to solve the few
problems that were actually happening in
the show and then we're pretty much done
so this is just pointing out that the
writing wasn't very good make it better
in some way God I hope so always we risk
making any future She-Hulk or even
Marvel projects less captivating by
having a super meta character that can
literally change the script of the shows
and movies she's in I don't think you
could ever go to medicine isn't that
right future me no editing this video
you know that's a great question but
again I'm not like I'm just filming
myself pretending to edit this video you
know I'm not actually editing this right
now oh maybe we should check with the
comments section of this video I mean
what do you guys think down there
super easy barley and inconvenience
right okay that's pretty much all they
say down there I think so anyway what do
you think would you just zone out for
like 30 seconds so anyway what do you
think I mean it sounds like a pretty
good time
a little something to make sure that
people tune in I've got just the thing
bye
he didn't even talk at all about
Daredevil I know I'm surprised I'm
actually kind of surprised I mean it
makes for the the good sting but at the
same time there's enough Daredevil that
you could have actually you know
expounded upon now the obvious joke
would have been people kept tuning in
even if they weren't interested just to
see Daredevil appear and that people
wanted this to be daredevil show then
make fun of the sex life with Jen and
Matt but I guess these are all so
obvious yeah like what I'm doing right
now yeah and then so obvious and then
you would have the the producer guy
frequently asking is this where
Daredevil shows up oh and this is where
Daredevil shows up yeah before Daredevil
shows I was very predictable or it was
just that good that Ryan George couldn't
think of a way to poke holes in it right
that's right Flawless Victory MCU all
right guys well that was a hilarious
pitch meeting uh that was awesome I love
the meta part of it leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to pitch meetings
subscribe to the Ryan George YouTube
channel let's end this with a pig
David Gandy my friend it's time to unbox
whatever it is that you sent us let's do
this let's see what's going on here what
you got Marlon gando
oh I see bubble wraps I see the bubs
whoa
whoa whoa whoa that is wild that's the
coolest thing ever oh my God holy crap
that's crazy
you guys don't get to see this no but
that is amazing never oh my god I've
never seen such a thing before that's
going on the door and it's got a it's
got It's gotta it's got a yeah oh I'm so
excited sorry I didn't want to spoil it
what is it what it's Bigfoot it's a
Squatch clearly a big like animal yeah
it's a Sasquatch foot it's a yeah I know
it's got It's got one foot you and your
dumb jokes yeah you're the one with the
dumb joke not me with the literal
you're the dump truck we switched we
switched places today that's right it's
good it was good it says look at that
how cool that is I love this so much
like like oh my God the national parks
uh style sign like gray called David oh
David I love this I don't know what
inspired this this is amazing thank you
Salvage 2015 I am dazzled actually over
here before me okay I appreciate it
David David take it back and fix it
that's amazing thank you buddy oh I'm
gonna send you a message right now oh
that is so cool really appreciate it in
love with this it's gonna be hung on the
door thank you man
[Music]